listening to film courage women David
Blaine
and Kerry Wood I'm Lily
you had also said at one point it was
very surreal like being in a room with
with all these individuals at what point
did you go you know what Wow my life is
changing you know this is getting
serious can you kind of take us through
the day that the two of you knew that
your career had kind of crossed over
well being a kind of business i think is
kind of strange business because there's
two different kind of success you know
you're running through die over at
barneys who famous famous famous famous
and it broke broke broke broke so it's
like you know what sort of success so i
don't know i don't i don't feel like
we've gotten anywhere where what you're
talking about now okay all right we
appreciate modesty like that so very
fortunate of course to have been a part
of the projects that we have been able
to be part of so that's been very cool
in a sense on the flip side of that
about that coin we feel very fortunate